there's many studies that have been done
on basketball players a lack of sleep
can go through and interfere with
reaction time it can interfere with
visual acuity their ability to see the
ball at the speed of light and react to
it so that's the software things their
ability to think fast that really goes
down and that's diminished one second
for lebron james can mean the difference
between winning and losing right
louisa nicola welcome to the show
chris so happy to be here
how would you describe what you do for
work
well uh my company neuroathletics is
literally the intersection of
neuroscience and athletic performance
around six years ago i would say
six years ago 2016 i saw a gap in that
market where i was looking at athletes i
was training athletes i had a
neuroscience background and i thought
why is everybody obsessed with making
these athletes better by just working on
their speed and agility why are we not
working on their brains the brain is the
powerhouse of the entire system
so
that's what i did i just started my
company and started working on the brain
okay but you don't just work with
athletes right
correct so right now so at the start the
conception euro athletics was purely
athletes and then we moved into an only
major league soccer nfl and mba
pathway
and then just by chance two years ago we
are we got the attention of the finance
world and let me tell you their brains
are uh their brains are and die in need
of neuro athletics so we now service uh
some of the financial world what's the
similarities between a portfolio manager
and an athlete
lack of sleep first and foremost
secondly competitiveness
thirdly
they've got that ability to do whatever
it takes they're not just getting up for
a for a day job at 9am and putting their
suit on they have to train like athletes
to get the best results some of the guys
i'm working with tell me louise if i
don't make this trade tonight if i'm not
in the peak state to make a good trade i
could lose 30 million dollars
okay so slightly high stakes when you
actually put it like that you think oh
he's kicking a ball about you know he's
kicking a ball into a goal what does it
matter it's not 30 million um
you said that both of them were under
slept do you find that your athletes on
average are underslept is that something
specific to athletes or do you think
that this is just the entire world is
underslept and athletes are a subsection
of the world
very good question so i think everybody
not just athletes and portfolio managers
i think everybody is underslept now just
12 hours ago on twitter i posted a tweet
saying guys i think i have it all wrong
i've been talking about sleep
deprivation but instead why don't i talk
about why don't we say rem sleep
deprivation or slow wave sleep
deprivation i think i think we've got it
all wrong when we talk about sleep
deprivation now
a lot of people in society are sleep
deprived now sleep deprived is
classified as six hours or less i live
in new york city almost everybody in the
city is sleeping six hours or less it's
a hustle city but then also now because
of technology because of what we're
eating because of how we're going out
the fact that the pandemic has brought
us inside we are being exposed to things
that are keeping us up longer throughout
the night but also disrupting
our patterns of getting into deep sleep
and slow and and rem sleep so i coined
this this new phenomenon i think of 2022
instead of somebody saying i'm sleep
deprived i'm gonna say well what part of
sleep deprived are you did are you
lacking rem sleep or you're lacking deep
sleep yeah well most people aren't
tracking on average you know there's
some freaks amongst us that are that
have got a whoop strap or that wear an
aura ring but
not many people are and it was only
when i started wearing a whoop strap
that i realized time in bed doesn't
equal time of sleep and time of sleep
doesn't always equal the same amount of
quality of sleep even though you you
wake up on the morning and you realize
there's something good right wrong side
of the bed syndrome um
but
the fact that even about whatever 85
percent efficiency or a 90 efficiency
say which is pretty good like it's
that's all right um
you need to be in bed for nine hours to
get eight hours and the number of people
that are in bed for nine hours is
basically zero
yeah and sometimes that's a struggle for
me especially now being in australia but
here's the thing you're wearing a root
strap so i wear all three now what we
know when we're talking about sleep
physiology in order to really understand
sleep apnea okay i'll go through a sleep
so you have to go into a lab and they
hook you up with all of these machines
they start with the head the eyes you've
got an oximeter a nasal cannula now
that is that that gives you a very
precise measurement okay of your sleep
stages how can we possibly mimic that
outside of the lab well companies such
as aura whoop other companies have now
invented these wearables but the
accuracy is where i
i think we need to talk about you're
wearing a work i'm wearing an aura right
now
studies show that the aura has a better
psg reading sleep study reading what's
psg
oh it's a polysomnography that's
basically a sleep study okay
so
it kind of mimics i think it was the
statistics are around 87 percent it
mimics what's happening in the lab
whereas the root strap is a bit
different it's more so better for
exercise and performance and hrv
tracking do you know what the percentage
was for the whoop
i don't but my thing is when i wear the
whip sometimes at night it can be it
slides around on your hand sometimes you
wake up and it's like misfolded
so maybe that's the uh maybe that's
what's happening
getting back to brain health we'll talk
about sleep in a bit but what what do
you mean when you talk about a high
performing brain what is that
so we've got when we look at the brain
we've got both the software and the
hardware the hardware being the actual
brain itself okay and we can have many
problems wrong with that for example
when an nfl player has a concussion
that's really messing with the hardware
okay they could have a dent in their
brain they could build up taopathies
within that area but then there's the
software which is how are you thinking
how are you feeling what are your
thoughts doing in your brain it's like
the cognitive part of it how's your
reaction time so i work with both of
those now with anything
in terms of progression how we're meant
to measure things so what we do with all
of our athletes is we measure them in
month one they come into they come and
see us whether it's in person or whether
it's online and we do an actual eeg scan
so we put a cap on them we're measuring
their brain waves we're understanding
what's happening with both the software
and the hardware and then from that we
then put in a a performance program and
that could consist of
upping their vitamins or upping their
epa dha which is known as fish oil we
look at sleep because sleep has an
impact on the brain we look at reaction
time we look at visual acuity and we
even do breath work because breath work
is another major factor affecting the
hardware and the software
so if i would say if you've got a high
performing brain there's probably about
10 different set points and if you're at
10 10 10 out of 10 for all of those set
points then that would be a high
performing brain what does it look like
on a biological level
you're a bit so do you mean like what's
the when you go inside of a scan what do
you see do you see more connections is
it to do with the speed of the synapses
firing what's actually mean
so it's the speed okay it's the speed we
look at um we look at information
processing speed your ability for your
eyes to perceive a stimulus relay it
back to your brain and for your brain to
understand what it is
so that speed it could be 0.4 it could
be 1.4
so obviously the 0.4 would be better and
this is measured in milliseconds so why
do we want that well you think of
driving a lot of traffic accidents
happen on the road because of reaction
time or sleep deprivation so we're
looking at everything your ability to
make a decision at work whether to make
the trade or not make the trade to make
the phone call and not make the phone
call is all dependent on your
information processing speed and then
there's also decision making skills so
when they're doing the scan
they're looking at it's not just a scan
like it's a hospital grade eeg but
you're not just sitting there you're
doing a task we can have them reacting
to something on the screen so it
measures that in real time
what sort of things are you getting them
to do what are the tasks
look i i spent 16 hours uh with that eeg
on watching one of our nba players just
do jump shots it was a very hard day
hang on he's got the cap on while he's
training
yeah we just had him doing jump shots
and i was literally measuring
what is happening when he's getting the
ball in the basket and i don't speak
technical when i'm talking about sports
because i just don't know the
technicality of it right i understand
that must be
you so there'll be a particular pathway
right there'll be a sequence a common
sequence of particular neurons that need
to fire in order for the
throw the ball toward the basket
yeah actually to be deployed
and we can put this on a a trader for
example
entire month and we can measure at what
time what was his brain doing at the
time he made a good trade what was his
brain doing at the time he made a bad
trade so then we can then predict we can
then pull the software and predict when
he's going to make a good trade or not
um what are the main principles that
people should consider when they're
trying to maximize their brains
performance
oh gosh
do you have a few days yep
yes so first one that i and i'm going to
talk about the ones that i think are not
spoken about okay that are looked over
first one is hydration
chris you've you've been drinking some
water i've only been on this core for 15
minutes okay you're hydrating it's so
important for the brain to be hydrated
now we have anywhere from 80 billion
neurons in the brain nerve cells in
order for them to think react produce a
movement or do anything those two brain
cells need to synapse together you
mentioned that earlier that's when they
fire together
in order for them to fight fire together
we have a pump called the sodium
potassium pump so literally our brain
where have you heard sodium or potassium
electrolytes right
so our brain really needs to be hydrated
to literally do anything
when we're dehydrated we're not thinking
straight we're not being able to produce
many things so i always say keep
hydrated not just with water but with
electrolytes too so we have an
electrolyte protocol at neuroathletics
we do sweat tests
so
some of our athletes are sweating a lot
more than the others and we determine
that swept test we think okay if you're
sweating this much this is how many
electrolytes you're losing so we dose
them for that pre-game post game and
throughout the day so that's number one
okay the second thing is consistency
your brain is actually pretty dumb okay
it's just this hunk of meat sitting
inside your skull but it likes
consistency it likes to wake up at the
same time every day and go to sleep at
the same time every day it also doesn't
like to be shocked when it's shocked it
doesn't it's not really prepared for
anything
so consistency with sleep routines
morning routines eating habits etc
then we can move on to more of the
pharmacological aspect now
outside of normal pathologies if you've
got any diseases etc there are certain
nutrients that our brain likes our brain
is literally made
of
dha and if you look at an omega-3
supplement a fish oil okay omega-3s
consist of epa dha and ala
so i'm always supplementing with epa dha
i do two milligrams in the morning two
milligrams at night there's so many
benefits you're not just feeding your
brain but you're also lowering
inflammation we know that inflammation
in a chronic state is bad for us both
neurally and physiologically so one of
the utmost biggest protocols that we do
with our athletes is you've got to be
having epa dha i would urge you know
everybody out there to be looking at the
scientific literature on that do you
have any brands that you suggest
particularly because i'm going to guess
that there's some changes in the quality
oh yeah i speak about that as well
manufacturing right now is that
it's a scary thing out there you don't
know sometimes what you're buying you
know some of the some of the drugs that
they're selling just at the supermarket
you know you don't know what they're
laced with so manufacturers matter now
the brand that i use is thorn
t-h-o-r-n-e
why well they've got so many
certifications i know them
like i've gone in i've really researched
i've done my research on them
manufacturing is clean and you also want
when you're having an epa dha sometimes
you know that the quality
of an of a fish oil when you have it and
you feel that you can taste the
fishiness of it have you ever felt that
and it's like this is disgusting yes
yes so that's how you know the quality
of it so it really matters what you're
having okay if when you're ingesting it
and if you're when you're ingesting the
epa dha if it smells it's got that fishy
smell or taste you know it's not of good
quality so
everything else you know when we're
talking about supplementation we do that
okay but then there's also what are you
supplementing at night to get a good
quality sleep okay because we know that
sleep is one of the determining factors
of brain performance so what are you
doing at night to get yourself into deep
sleep stages now
i have a i have a sleep stack i would
say a sleep protocol and it consists of
the first one is
magnesium l3 and 8.
i take this every night
first and foremost magnesium okay we
know magnesium that should be good for
the body there's three types of
magnesium we have it when we want to
stressfully even have you know better
functioning muscles recovery etc but
there's one magnesium out of those three
that crosses the blood-brain barrier and
that is magnesium l3 and 8. so once it
crosses a blood-brain barrier it's going
to calm down your nervous system it's
going to get you into deep sleep
so that's the one of the the sleep
protocols that we have magnesium l3na
and then for some of our athletes or
clients some of them are feeling as if
they've got a racing mind at night
so we may get them to supplement with
gaba which is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter so these are the things
that um you know without wafting on too
much that you can be doing at night or
during the day what's your thoughts on
5htp
i don't supplement with it but i'm
noticing a lot of
men asking me this question
not women fruit so
i can't comment on it because i don't
have it but i have noticed that angie
huberman talks about that a bit okay
what about dosage for the magnesium what
would you aim for
um
it's a so the one that i get is from
pure encapsulations or life extension
it's a blue bottle and you have to take
three at night exactly so you're just
following the recommended dosage based
on whatever it says on the bottle
well yeah yeah cool okay yeah there's um
jigsaw health to a mag srt and that's
one that's pretty well touted ben
greenfield's a big fan of that that's
pretty good
yeah yeah it is um they have a magnesium
chelate pre-bed
drink thing which is okay but because
it's
it must have some sort of bicarb in it
or something to help it mix with the
water and if you have that last thing
before you go to bed i always end up
finding myself needing to sit up and
burp it's like the most
weird byproduct of having a sleep drink
do you think oh yeah but the fact that
it's fizzy means that i need to so
anyway what about um exercises so let's
say that that's some of the principles
behind making your brain healthier what
about things that people could do
exercises that you take your athletes
and your traders through to try and
improve their mental capacity
oh so many so one thing that we focus on
is
zone two training and that's when you're
you know we've got different zones of
training obviously maybe zone five would
be at maximum
zone two is that comfortable pace
where
you can talk but you're also exercising
okay and we measure this through our vo2
max testing so we do a lot of zone two
and the reason being is that this area
of exercise is the most efficient to be
training the quality of the mitochondria
the mitochondria are the powerhouse of
the cell so
once we get out of a zone three once we
get into zone three and zone four we're
training outside of that mitochondria so
that's one area that we train because we
also focus on longevity okay everyone
knows that an athlete has an expiration
date so we're focusing on longevity as
well
but the next part of it is so the reason
why neuroathletics really
came into play or existed was because
i was doing a lot of reaction training
you know i was working just with a
tennis ball and a couple of lights back
in 2016 just getting them to throw the
ball to the wall and what i found this
was doing was it was training different
areas of the brain we're working on
hand-eye coordination so their ability
to see a target catch a ball use
reflexes and then i started working from
there i got them to stand on one foot
through the ball to the wall
contralateral movements with the brain
so we were doing so much with hand-eye
coordination and that's how
neuro-athletics really came into play so
if you want to do any anything for your
brain in terms of exercise and train it
towards fatigue you want to be doing you
just want to get a tennis ball we're
actually going to bring out some neural
balls but i'm trying to figure out a way
to
to name that better
yeah nero anything with balls in is
is going to be difficult just going back
to the zone two uh
duration and frequency per week what
would you say
three times per week or one hour or
around 50 minutes at minimum okay so
it's a big commitment for this
especially if you're an athlete you've
got your other training to do skills and
work and stamina and blah blah on top um
but i suppose
that's probably not a bad active
recovery day
exactly is that how you try to use it
i use it like that depending on who i'm
talking to because some of the um i've
got you know a 56 year old male who's in
the trading business and i he's
he may be very unhealthy so i'll just
get him to do zone two yeah three hours
a week and he does that on a stationary
bike it's so easy he's got one set up in
the living room he's got kids so he's
just on that no hard
what's the
heart rate range that people should be
aiming for to hits onto ish
well see this is the thing that the the
science suggests that you shouldn't just
work on heart rate but for my athletes
we do okay because i do a vo2 max test
for them yours is always rated against
what their max is
exactly everybody's different but if you
want to measure it it's really around 65
of maximum hr which you know is really
easy it's just walking around really
am i right in thinking that zone 2 for
that sort of duration for that sort of
frequency is also
what would be prescribed if you wanted
to raise the ceiling on your hrv as well
well yeah look so hiv is another
it can it can raise hiv values yes and
that's purely because you're working
within that space you're working on the
mitochondria if you really want to get
technical you want to measure your blood
lactate and that's what we do the only
caveat on that is
who wants to pinprick themselves every
time they're riding right okay
blood let's say that someone does want
to take the ceiling of that hiv up what
would your prescription be for that
person
well we know that hiv or heart rate
variability reflects how adaptable your
body can be it measures the specific
changes in time between successive
heartbeats so we know that we've got
resting heart rate we've got we've got
our actual heart rate we know that it's
measuring the time between those two
heartbeats okay and especially basically
a measure of your autonomic nervous
system which is everything that is
happening automatically so we know it's
a good measurement of health and
recovery
so if we want to be working on that then
we know that okay first and foremost
we need to really have a recovery day
okay or we need to be doing recovery
things during the day
second thing is it's dependent on
food intake okay or the quality or if
you're having alcohol or any type of
drugs per se that's going to go in and
mess with your sympathetic and
parasympathetic nervous system okay so
we we want to we want a way to stabilize
everything
so sleeping well
sleeping consistently
hydrating
getting adequate exercise all of these
things are going to
eventuate into a higher or more stable
hiv
that is
keeping hiv more stable and also acutely
making it as optimal as possible how
about raising the ceiling of hrv overall
taking it from 100 or a maximum green
recovery on your whoop being
70 to a maximum green now being able to
be 80 or 90 or 100 what are some of the
things that you could do to raise that
ceiling
well it's measured during sleep okay so
that's i don't know if you know that but
it basically goes in
uh whether it's an orange or whether
it's a workshop you're basically going
in and it's taking a two minute two to
four minute measurement during your
sleep so if we're not in a deep sleep
stage or we're not we haven't recovered
properly you're not going to get a high
enough value so if we really want to
raise the roof then i would say the
number one thing you need to work on is
sleep
okay cool what about
the impact of sleep on brain performance
then what are the what are the impacts
that you see there
look
it's not just brain performance it's
also immunity okay so
sleep or sleep deprivation plays a
number of key roles okay now i've pulled
up um if you don't mind i've pulled up a
study that i reference a lot but i
really want to get it right for you and
your audience okay there was a really
very famous study and it was done in in
the journal of pnas what they did was
they took a group of healthy adults and
they limited them to six hours of sleep
a day for one week
they found a change in the activity of
711
genes
okay so we've got a gene
our genes our epigenetic poor we've got
the human genome is around 20 000 genes
from getting lack of sleep of six hours
a night resulted in the change of 711
genes that's around three percent of our
entire genome
what they found was out of that 711
about half of the genes were upregulated
and half of them were down regulated
okay
the ones that were impaired when we say
down regulated that means impaired
the genes that were down regulated
were the ones associated with the immune
system
okay and the ones that were up regulated
were the ones associated with tumor
production long-term chronic
inflammation cardiovascular disease
so that's really important to know that
only after one week
you're changing
your epigenetics you're changing your
human gene you're changing the genes
that's it that's insane to think about
right
because we're all sleeping sometimes
we've gone through a week i'm sure
you've gone through literally seven days
of sleep deprivation somewhere in your
life
especially for for new parents out there
and in that time you're probably finding
that
you know when you're working so hard and
then all of a sudden when you stop you
get sick
so that's the same thing so it's pretty
much the same thing so
sleep deprivation of sleep impacts
immunity okay but then let's go into
more of an another thing and i'll give
you the link to that um to that article
let's talk about why
athletes need sleep first of all
back to the software okay what we see
there's many studies that have been done
on basketball players but we see that a
lack of sleep can go through and
interfere with reaction time it can
interfere with visual acuity their
ability to see the ball at the speed of
light and react to it okay so that's
that's the software things their ability
to think fast that really goes down and
that's diminished which one second for
lebron james can mean the difference
between winning and losing right
that's the first thing but then let's
look at
more of a hardware thing okay
when we fall asleep
we go through three stages of sleep in
the first in the first third of the
night okay we go through stage one two
and three that's comprised of deep sleep
okay slow wave sleep
during these stages there's one really
critical thing that happens and that's
hormone secretion
hormones are released during that stage
okay it's predominantly in stage three
which is slow wave deep sleep
these hormones are human growth hormone
and testosterone
so for yourself chris if you're not
getting into those deep sleep stages
you're not going to be getting the
adequate release of human growth hormone
or testosterone
so human growth hormone is responsible
for protein synthesis and recovery and a
whole bunch of other things
babies sleep a lot and that's why they
grow fast because they've got a lot of
human growth hormone
and then have you ever heard of the
saying or maybe seen men that have got
breasts
[Laughter]
man titties call them what they are
louisa listen
well whatever you want to call them you
could say that it's a build up of
estrogen and a lack of testosterone okay
maybe because they're not getting into
that deep sleep stage do you see a
typical before you start working with
the guys that you're floor traders do
you see a particular body style i mean
are they built like bags of milk mostly
yes i do and i that's the first thing i
say and they get really upset but hey
tell them that you tell these guys that
are making 30 million dollar trades that
they built like bad bags of milk
i go too much
and you don't sleep and they're like
and they're not really coming to me with
their shirts off either i can just see
it i'm like no no leave your shirt on
it's fine please see it for the lovers
all that is holy
so so many different things happen
during deep sleep and then we move on to
rem sleep rapid eye movement sleep now
during this time your body is completely
paralyzed but your brain is still active
it's what we call it the dream sleep
state but
what else happens during this stage well
we get
things such as learning so learn memory
consolidation and all of the learning
takes place during rem sleep so if we're
not getting into these these two stages
it's really going to mess us up the
following day we're going to wake up
with brain fog we're going to wake up
feeling irritable we're not going to be
remembering things we're also not going
to be able to execute to the best of our
abilities
so we really need to be optimizing for
sleep and that's a that's a really big
thing that we focus on at euro athletics
because there's coaches out there so we
work with one particular nba team and
i'm actually going through and coaching
the trainers and the coaches because
they're like well we didn't know this
everyone's just working on the co and
the ball skills you know
no one thinks about what's happening
when they go home at night
how long did you play xbox for what time
did you get up what's your pre-bed
routine like
yeah it's um
what how does how does sleep debt and
sleep repayment work is that a thing
no sleep is not like a bank so if you're
going to debt you can't go through and
pay it back
so once you lose sleep that's it you're
done that's why i don't like binge
sleepers people who are like it's okay
i'll sleep five hours during the week
maximum productivity and then just
you know build it up on the weekends it
doesn't work like that that's a shame
yeah because that would be well i mean
what can you do let's say that you do
have a bad night's sleep presumably
sleeping a little bit more the following
night isn't a bad idea
well no of course not there was actually
i just put out
two weeks ago there was a study that was
just um that's just come out and very
high stringent journal that says there's
no such thing as as too much sleep
okay
meaning
sorry meaning that we know what happens
we know the effects of sleep deprivation
of the brain and the body but when you
have too much sleep there's not really
much that happens you just
maybe you've you might get a bit fatter
over the course of
there's nothing bad that happens which i
think is great but
that would be a good
study to run you know if you can try and
somehow get people to sleep
12 hours a night or 14 hours a day i
guess for seven days or 14 days and try
and record the changes there that'd be
really interesting
i'd be more interested in finding out
why they have time to sleep that much
because they're not high-powered floor
traders that's why
they're not selling selling their soul
at goldman sachs that's the reason why i
mean so here's another thing that i've
got in my mind there must be attention
you go into these high-powered trading
floors i think the athletes
on the whole probably
would be more accommodating to
i understand that i need to sleep
this is my entire life it's geared
around performance but not many people
treat
their output at work on a trading floor
with the same level of rigor that
athletes do right they're not going in
to get a massage to loosen off whatever
it is or the equivalent mentally
how do you get someone who isn't
bought into the world of i need more
sleep than i'm getting
high-powered go-getting taipei people or
massive ties and pinstripe suits how do
you get them to
let go of that sort of hustle and grind
mentality
well actually i find the reverse okay i
find and i didn't ever think this i see
the sporting world as you know i've got
some athletes who say to me well louise
i'm i am number one
or i'm in the mba what's the you know i
don't i don't want to be like lebron i'm
already in the mba i'm doing better than
99 of the world i don't really need to
get better they're the ones that annoy
me whereas the traders are the ones who
say well if i'm not at that state
then i'm going to lose 30 million so
they do everything they can actually
they're more coherent and obedient to
the method than your athletics method
than the athletes that's awesome
yeah both of them do
do go through jet lag a lot of them are
both groups are flying okay
so that's another thing that you know
the athletes are getting on and off
planes especially during the playoffs
some of them are doing three pla three
flights a week
and they're feeling it and they're just
a bit you know like so we've got jet lag
protocols as well whereas the
there's more consistency in the finance
world
yeah that's interesting i suppose the
markets are always going to open at the
same time which is going to give them
that sort of rigidity that they need
but also you think if a player is going
to play mediocre okay let's just say
he's in miami heat he plays mediocre
he's not going to lose 30 million he
might just
just not play as well but he's got the
team carrying him
if the day trader needs to make a trade
on saturday at 3 a.m he makes a mediocre
trade he can lose a lot of money
okay so the pressure on a trading floor
is much more on the individual and the
changes in his performance are a lot
more acute yeah that's that's
interesting i suppose specifically with
basketball um it is such a team sport
you know you could have you could
probably have a player that has an
absolute stinker of a game and the teams
still win and maybe the coaches think oh
you had a bad day but they'll
probably forget about it because the
team won as opposed to the
accountability that you get being on a
trading floor
and if you make that bad decision and
you're 30 grand in the red someone
somewhere is going to come and shout at
you
oh yeah or you've like lost the life
savings of a family
or that yes what are talk me through
your um pre-beds or your optimal pre-bed
routines you know i know that everyone
that's listening will be familiar with
the digital sunset but
realistically what's the sort of
minimum viable dose or the most
compliant easy routine that somebody
could go through before they go to bed
on a night
well the first thing i start with don't
make it law just do it as many times
throughout the week that you can if you
knock off three nights a week great next
week we'll work on four the first thing
is
not eating three hours prior to falling
asleep anything at all
yeah we don't want any activity we don't
want any raises in cortisol and that's
what happens when you eat we don't want
anything digesting that's the first
thing okay the second thing is obviously
we're not going to be having any
caffeine past the out the caffeine has a
half-life of 12 hours but i want
caffeine past 12 p.m
okay that's the first thing i always say
that you're preparing for sleep the
moment that you wake up okay now one
really important one i struggle with
this every day and that's eliminating
like you said digital light but it
really is bad
so i know for some people they said well
louise i can't do that so i do get them
to wear blue light blocking glasses
although i don't particularly
believe in them 100 but it has some
small effect i've seen some mixed
studies about them
well it's
it doesn't block out all of the blue
light that's what the promise is but
it's not about that so if we just treat
it as if it blocks out some that's a
better thing to say because it's true it
doesn't block it all out so but we do
you know if we could be walking around
with x-ray vision at night then that
would be great so that is eliminating
light okay especially don't you don't
want to be looking at light between the
hours of 10 p.m and 4 a.m
now
that's that but then it's about there's
always two complaints that you have you
have to figure this out do you have a
problem falling asleep or do you have a
problem staying asleep so these two
things
offer different prescriptions
if you have a problem falling asleep
that means your brain's just
going at a million miles an hour so you
may be wanting to supplement with gaba
gamma-aminobutyric acid
but around a year ago i caught on to the
fact that there was a lot of research
that was being brought out about
temperature okay and the ability to
manipulate your core body temperature to
get into sleep
so
in order to fall asleep and stay asleep
our core body temperature needs to drop
at least two degrees
okay
so that's great so we can get cold but
then i realized that it's not about
ambient temperature it's not about you
can't just put the thermostat on or the
air conditioning and get really cold
it's about core body temperature the
only real way to do that is via two
things
first one is sleeping on a temperature
controlled mattress
or hiring somebody throughout the night
to just cool you down with with ice
packs
the latter probably isn't feasible so
you have to look at a cooling bed and
around a year ago i somebody said have
you seen eight sleep they're a sleep
fitness technology company i don't know
if you've heard of them but i in i
invested in one of their mattresses and
i had the best quality of sleep that
i've ever had and so i now sleep on an
eight sleep uh temperature controlled
mattress so basically it
it locates your heart rate okay and it
gets you one once it figures out oh
louise is in deep sleep it gets you into
that it drops your core body temperature
down by dropping the temperature of the
mattress and you're able to get into
those deep sleep stages how does it
detect that
it's actually you've got a um you've got
an app okay but also the bed because
it's technology driven it's picking up
on your heart rate so in the morning the
app actually
can pick up on your heart rate through
the mattress
it gives you hrv metrics in the morning
it says louise you slept um in your deep
sleep you did
the exact same things that you see with
your whoop it does the same thing wow
okay that's pretty impressive
yeah oh it's amazing and so i partnered
with the company because i harassed them
i said i need to be part of the movement
that you're doing so
now i have all my athletes sleeping on
that
so i got a chili pad mattress topper
which is a very very similar sort of
thing although it doesn't know when i am
where i am
and i took it off because it was winter
and i was using it to cool me down but
now maybe i'm thinking
that you're probably right because the
house is quite warm it's cold in the uk
at the moment
then ambient temperature is okay ish but
in the bed is completely different to
what you have going on outside the same
as whatever being in a hot country and
thinking that blasting the air con and
changing the temperature of the room is
going to change what happens underneath
the covers
exactly i don't know with the chili pad
though
it doesn't do heating does it yeah yeah
yeah it goes both ways yeah so the two
the second one which i've got is the
they've given it a stupid name and i
can't remember it so sully sorry chili
pad anyway it's the small one that goes
underneath it's like the oro or
something and that comes with an app uh
and the app you can change temperature
throughout the night it'll cool down to
just below 16 degrees celsius and it'll
heat up to
40 degrees or something unbelievably hot
and it'll move you throughout the night
it also has i think eight sleep has this
as well where it can wake you up with is
it heat
but it does vibration as well right
it does vibration it's very annoying
because it doesn't it's not irritating
because it doesn't stop until you get
out of bed
so it's like i want a bastard yeah so
sometimes like on a saturday i'll just
i'll jump out and then i'll come back
outwitted your bed you've done well what
about um reducing sleep
uh sorry reducing the amount of times
that you wake up throughout the night
then so that's sleep latency maybe some
gaba make sure that people are feeling a
little bit what about deep breathing and
stuff like that actually for sleep
latency any other tips
well let's just define sleep latency is
your time that it takes you to fall
asleep okay but when we're you know when
we're getting up throughout the night
okay so that's a different thing and
some people are waking up to go to the
bathroom usually with men over the age
of um i think it's around 65 to 70
they're waking up at 4am it's like a
thing okay and they're going to the
bathroom all men worldwide or nationwide
are getting up to go and have a wires at
the same time
exact same time it's funny um but what
can we be doing well you've got to
figure out why it is that you're waking
up but in order to like i said to you to
decrease that sleep latency
that comes down to not having a lot of
activity happening in your brain and
body breathing exercises okay breathing
exercises are amazing it calms down your
sympathetic nervous system activates the
parasympathetic rest and digest nervous
system so you're calmer
what would be a
protocol for that like box breathing or
something
i like box breathing but i actually have
a a 1 pm and like a 4 pm protocol which
is literally
being silent for 10 minutes that's all
it is because i noticed that if you put
in too many protocols like sit there put
candles on do this
um things like this it doesn't really
work out so all it is it's about 10
minutes of
silence it's very hard if you close your
eyes and you try and keep that
keep that notion happening it's very
hard but you can try it and start off
with that one thing that i woke up this
morning and one of my um she's a
portfolio manager she messaged me she's
like
had the best sleep of my life and my hiv
increased because of this one technique
and i'll tell it to you have you ever
taped your mouth during the night
i've tried it i've i've tried it yes um
it's a bit weird it never really seems
to stay in my mouth i don't know whether
i'm
trying to talk in my sleep or something
but yeah i've tried
or the sweat may have um ripped it off
not bad come on yeah i don't know but
i got that um but you
that's a great little hack
okay taping the mouth mouth breathing is
um is bad we don't want to be mouth
breathing so in order to really breathe
through your nose through night the
night you want to tape your mouth just
make sure that you don't um have any
breathing issues we don't want you
i've used so i've just started using
this year uh nasal strips to open my
airway up on my nose so you'll have seen
athletes use these before that's really
really nice especially if you have like
narrow uh nasal passages
that makes oh it's such a difference
yeah it's literally like constantly
having your nostrils flared so there's
so much more room it feels really lovely
it's really satisfying i have no idea i
haven't done it for long enough i've
only done it for maybe a week so i
haven't been able to compare but i've
tracked it on my woop because you can
give custom inputs about what you did
during the day so i've got days when i
did and days when i didn't and we'll see
if that makes
any difference but i mean by the end of
the night i asked ben greenfield about
this because i think his wife
is the most normal person on the planet
and ben greenfield is like the complete
opposite and i asked him what does she
think he's getting into bed he's got the
blue light block is on he's got
something stuck up his nose he's got his
finger on a hiv monitor all of this
crazy technology and apparently his wife
just like reads a dan brown novel and
falls and has the perf the perfect eight
hours sleep that nobody ever needs to to
try and alter um so yeah i think there
it well yeah but there are going to be
a lot of
very odd or disgruntled partners after
someone just decides to go to but
whatever you know you're already married
they can't leave now now that you've
decided to adopt a weird bedtime habit
um i want to talk about
the guys that you're dealing with
whether it be athletes or floor traders
about how you instruct them to stay calm
under pressure
oh
well that's uh that's hard and um to do
it in a healthy way it's all about
consistency and protocols so we have
this one protocol which literally every
time you think a bad thought every time
you're freaking out
you have to perform a drill it might be
a clicking draw which anchors your
thought okay or it might be practicing a
double inhale exhale like a
physiological side to calm down the
nervous system but what i find is no
matter how many
how many protocols you put in place for
that moment it's how strong are you and
how strict are you to activate them
during that stressful moment okay so
i've got one player on the miami heat
who i talk to every time he goes on
before he goes on the actual court
because he freaks out too much
okay and we we do video calls so and
you're talking this guy through
some cues what do you mean when you say
either a clicking or a double breath
inhale to anchor their thoughts what do
you mean
because when you're when you're freaking
out you're anxious your mind is going at
a million miles an hour you're thinking
so many things so if you just stop it
okay and change direction literally what
do you have to do when you're going down
a highway and you want to change
direction you have to stop eventually
and once you stop okay you can stop by
doing so clicking is like a form of your
brain is like okay i'm going to click
and there
they know through their protocol that in
order to click they have to anchor their
thought into something else
okay so that's kind of like noting in
mindfulness meditation
yeah
it's a it's in sports psychology there's
one method where they get you to wear an
elastic band around your wrist and every
time you have a panic they you slap your
wrist that's very old school though yeah
i've seen people doing that
so that's one but also sometimes if i'm
talking to someone it's just about
they're making things up in their head
everything that can go wrong okay i'm
gonna go on the court i'm gonna lose
this i'm not gonna get the ball i'm not
feeling good this is just calming that
down
[Music]
it's strange to think that players that
are professional athletes and do week in
week out still have the same sort of
nervousness that
a normal person would do before they go
and give
a talk or whatever it is
it gives a different perspective when
you see a good example might be someone
like jake paul who is very new into the
sport of boxing
putting him in the athletic
i i'm trying to be delicate here but my
point is that you have someone who isn't
a trained athlete who hasn't gone
through
years decades
several iterations of walking out in
front of a huge crowd and yeah i uh
i don't know i have a friend who's a a
very high level dj and he
every single time before he steps behind
the decks throws up every single time
every single one of them because that's
how nervous he is because he wants to do
well and he is playing in front of 10
000 people at madison square garden or
whatever it might be and every single
time before he goes out he throws up
wow
that's yeah no look
anybody i i say athlete but i mean
anybody performing at a high level and
he obviously is too yeah it's scary
what about research on heat and cold
exposure is there any new cool stuff
that you've seen recently on that
i'm actually about to get i love cold
immersion i speak about it i've got a
podcast dedicated to it
i'm actually getting my first ice bath
it's going to come here to sydney
because i can't fit it in the new york
city apartment but um it's absolutely
incredible
okay there's so much research around
this to suggest that this is
so
important to do to
literally bring down the um the
inflammatory biomarkers responsible for
inflammation that's the first thing okay
immersing yourself in cold water we know
that there is a pathway now where you
get into cold water and these the
pathway can go up to your brain and have
a really good effect of decreasing
neural inflammation but one thing that i
love about it is that once you get into
cold water
within about five minutes you get this
massive release
of not just cold shock proteins but we
get a massive release of norepinephrine
and that is that it's both a hormone
okay and a neurotransmitter and as a
neurotransmitter it is responsible for
focus and vigilance so if you want to
get that if you i think everyone every
morning should be doing some form of
cold therapy i absolutely love it i do
it you just got to be really really
strict to not do it straight after
training because once we do that what we
do is we block the hormetic response of
hypertrophy so when we go and work out
okay we're working out our muscles we're
strengthening them we want them to
create a bit of inflammation so they
tear a bit and rebuild that's what makes
them stronger and if we go and stop that
rebuilding by blocking those pathways
through cold we're not going to get the
effects
so cold immersion love it
everybody should get a cold bath give me
your optimal cold immersion protocol
across a week what would you prescribe
to someone
i don't do it for less than 12 minutes
and that's really hard depending at the
temperature so
far i'm not going to speak fahrenheit
because it's not my first language but
in terms of um i do i've got a i've got
a thermometer inside the bath and it
drops to around 12 degrees which is
freezing celsius or yeah right okay
um
and you're doing that for you said 12 no
less than 12 minutes no less than 12
minutes sometimes it goes down to nine
how many how many times a week
i try and do this five times a week wow
so i saw hubermann had posted not long
ago saying that the most recent research
suggested uh nine minutes of cold
exposure a week and you're doing what 60
so there seems to be a big disparity
between those two what's the reason for
choosing 12 and five times
well i mean i that's what when i found
this you know in the scientific
literature it said you've got to be
doing this at least once once a day
really it's like when people say well
why can't i just get into a what's the
cryotherapy chamber it's not going to do
you any
oh yeah it's not going to do you
anything it's just i feel like it's
gimmicky and no one's gonna no one has
ninety dollars i think it's like ninety
dollars a session to do this every day i
think at bare minimum the science says
okay bare minimum three times a week
okay bare minimum
i'm just crazy all right just been as
having a coffee enema
have you had a look at contrast therapy
um ronda patrick was talking about this
that's going from the heat to the cold
um is there any research about whether
that's as effective more effective less
effective
she actually says i i saw um she put
this she was on joe rogan and she said
that the science she goes it makes her
feel good so can have a placebo effect
but the science isn't there to suggest
that you're getting more benefits from
doing cold shock heat shock cold shock
heat shock so they're two different
they're two different pathways i prefer
the cold but i you know if i can one day
get a sauna infrared sauna single person
then i would because the effects that
you get on the cardiovascular system are
fantastic you know imagine saying that
you can get those effects the heat shock
proteins that are both neuroprotective
and they help with the cardiovascular
system imagine if you could do that for
20 minutes and mimic a one hour or two
hour ride on the bike
yeah i'd rather i'd rather do the the
sauna right yeah the um
there's a place in austin called kuya
which is a wellness recovery center uh
ketamine psychotherapy and vitamin ivs
and stuff but it also has a
two cold tubs and a sauna and they do
contrast therapy or they suggest
contrast therapy and it is one of the
good things about going from the sauna
into the ice bath is that because you
were so hot
when you get into the ice bath the
initial
cold is easier to tolerate and then as
you stay in there over time obviously
that um what's it called agitator in the
tank is continuing to flow cold water in
but
you are it the it's a reverse of the
frog in boiling water it's the man in
tiny swim shorts in the ice bath but it
gets easier to do it that way and then i
also find that getting into the sauna
after that as well you've got a little
bit of time to bring yourself back up so
i think your tolerance on both increases
but yeah i'd be interested to know
what research
ends up coming out around contrast
therapy about whether going from the
extreme of heat to cold and back again
actually is advantageous or not
let's look at look at it clinically and
this is why i don't think it's the best
thing if you're going if you're putting
your body into a hypothermic
okay and then a hyperthermic hyper hot
hypo low cold i don't think that's good
for the systems i don't think doing that
to your heart or your body would be
beneficial i think just dropping it down
and staying there and just doing that
and maybe later on a few hours later
getting into the opposite effect would
be better i don't think going like this
is necessary because i've actually tried
it i've got to tell you i was so dizzy i
almost i felt like i was going to faint
what about heat exposure what's your
favorite
protocol for that or how much would you
suggest that people do
so you can also do this by getting into
a hot bath which is something that i do
with magnesium okay because i don't have
a sauna um
magnesium in the bath
yeah magnesium salt okay why
calms my body down makes me very very
sleepy
you're literally soaking in the
magnesium through the largest organ in
the body which is the skin
and heat makes you sleepy anyway
so it prepares you for bed that's
another protocol people should try but
um i think the i think the protocol is
to get the benefits for the cardiac
vascular system of the heat shock
proteins i think you've got to stay in
there around 20 minutes 23 minutes okay
um
i've definitely noticed
when you go into a
sauna if you're in there for about 10 to
15 minutes it begins to get difficult
and then if you stain for a little
longer there's a tingly sensation it's
is that the heat shock proteins is that
the feedback of the heat shock proteins
being released or is there any way that
you know when you've got to that because
obviously you can be in a sauna for
20 minutes or 23 minutes or 25 minutes
but presumably if it was
20 degrees hotter you would have hit
that point after 15 minutes or whatever
it is so is there a way that people can
tell when they've been in for long
enough
i'll tell you something that's really
fascinating okay there's have you heard
of hormesis yes
so it's pretty much
um
when your body has to survive so
survival of the fittest okay so when you
feel at that moment where you're about
to die okay
that's when the effect comes in and
that's the hormetic response so if you
look at longevity studies if you look at
centenarians people who live to 100 it's
because they've they've gotten into that
state of whatever doesn't there we go
that's it whatever doesn't kill you
makes you stronger that's what hormesis
is
so if you can be doing this that's why
heat shock proteins and why cold shock
proteins exist to put us in that
survival mode okay so it's at that point
that's why i don't really believe in
cold showers to mimic these people like
well i do cold therapy i do cold showers
it's like but it's just a cold shower
that's not shocking your body to
that survival mode right there's a big
difference between immersing yourself
for five minutes and even doing a a cold
shower because it's never
it never just sinks in through your skin
for as long right there's not as much
time that your body is being in contact
with cold
temperatures you get out of the ice bath
and
you're shivering sometimes if you've
been in for long enough
oh yeah and that shivering is a great
response okay that's that that
non-shivering thermogenesis or the
shivering actually activates brown fat
or brown adipose tissue
am i right in thinking that you're
supposed to have wrists and clavicle
under as well for something to do with
brown
tissue literally
neck down
okay
is that just to immerse the most of you
or is there something special about
those areas
no that's just to get the most of the uh
the immersion possible
sometimes i put my feet at the end of
the bath but
what about psychedelics and lsd
for enhancing sport performance didn't
you look at something to do with this
i did i wrote a i wrote a stack so i
have a weekly newsletter that goes out
and we tapped into this because i spoke
to dave robin and he's um he's at the
forefront he's a psychiatrist he's at
the forefront of psychedelic medicine
and
look
i think it's going to be great not for
sports performance i think it's going to
be great for the treatment of depression
and i'm all i'm all for it i think it's
um i think it's amazing i'm excited to
see how it can be done clinically
with a trained professional
but only in that area i don't know if i
i would think that there's any
correlation maybe this is just me um
correlation yet with sporting
performance you don't think players
playing off their face imagining bright
green
footballs flying towards them and stuff
like that and a dragon in the sky you
don't think that's performance enhancing
well i wrote about this famous i figured
what his name is i figured what year but
he had his best hit um he was a
baseballer he's best hit done on lsd
no way
yeah yeah i've got it on my sub stack
i'll send it to you but it's um it's
fascinating research and that could just
be because maybe he was karma he was
just you know
apparently it you know
when you're dosing
or micro dosing with psychedelics
whichever one maybe it's lsd or
psilocybin you are tapping into that
creativity mode okay so maybe that could
have had an effect on it well they're
definitely connecting synapses that
don't usually right different areas of
the brain that aren't usually
communicating with each other as enabled
when the default mode network gets
switched off um
it does surprise me that someone's able
to do
swing anything at anything if they're on
lsd but
well it depends on dosage as well
yeah yeah yeah true if it's whatever
what's it sub
awareness below the threshold of
awareness whatever it is
well you can have you can tap into the
area that's going to be clinically benef
benefit beneficial for you
or you can tap into that one that makes
people jump off
of a roof right get that one get the
second one that's the one that we want
what was the
i heard you talking about so we've
spoken about throwing a tennis ball at a
wall what was the fact
something to do with standing on your
left foot and throwing with your right
what was that
so
left brain and right brain we've got two
hemispheres okay they're connected by a
bridge
left part of the brain is responsible
for the right part of the body right
side of the body right side of the brain
is responsible for the left side it's
like this x it's a contralateral it's
how we see as well
i love the fact that you can be working
on the left brain okay your brain is
having to think and see but you're
actually producing the movement with
your right hand
so we do a lot of things where i'll get
them to lift their leg up their left leg
up so they're standing on their right
leg and they're throwing the ball to the
wall with their right hand
also one thing that i get all my
athletes to do at some point is wear an
eye patch literally if you go to the the
pharmacy you get an eye patch for if
you've got an eye infection put that on
and it blocks out one part of their eye
or blocks out the vision of their eye so
this that means if you're going to block
out the right eye means the left eye is
going to get stronger because it's only
got one one
eye to see so it's going to have to scan
everything
so it's progressive overload for your
eye are you familiar with slack block do
you know what a slack block is
no that was gonna say are they the
the goggles no so you know what a slack
line is right which is kind of like a
tightrope thing that you tie between
trees and hippies do it in la so the
slack block is a small
around about two feet long and it's a
kind of like a skateboard deck that's
about the width of a foot and it sits on
a
pyramid of foam
you have seen these
yeah i have seen these yeah yeah they're
dope they're so good
yeah really really good balancing right
correct yeah so what i was doing i
ruptured my achilles about 18 months ago
and one of the things that i was advised
to do was any sort of standing on one
leg whilst throwing a tennis ball at the
wall so the reason to do that is that it
causes you to need to readjust
constantly you know the ball goes to the
wall you got to readjust it catch again
got to readjust
and i worked up to doing it on the slack
block and what you do is you take
columns of foam out so you can imagine
that there's columns cut through it and
as you take more of them out there's
less structure below the skateboard deck
which means that it becomes more and
more
difficult to keep your balance on and
over time you can work so it's in the
kitchen so a lot of the time i'll go in
and one of the boys will be stood on it
like trying to chop stuff i'm like this
is a recipe for disaster but um doing
that whilst throwing a ball at the wall
the progression that you see in terms of
your balance your uh judgment was really
really high
do you know what's interesting they say
that you can't have proper brain health
without having good balance now the
there's a little area underneath the
brain it's separate from the brain but
it's it's called the cerebellum
literally means in latin um mini brain
looks like a mini brain and that's the
area that's responsible for posture and
balance so you can literally train that
area of the brain by standing on one leg
or by standing on a balance board or by
standing on a whatever you're doing and
that's another thing that we do but one
thing you know i mentioned earlier was
these strobe goggles so we have these
goggles right and they've imagined just
one
one part of the the right side and it's
cut into four it's cut in quadrants
so i can program it for my athletes to
see all three quadrants
and then block out the upper right
and what does that do why why why do
they need that
well we see in the four quadrants so
that means that they're going to be
strengthening all of the areas in the
eye except for the one blacked out
okay to overcompensate where can people
go if they want to check out your sub
stack and follow more of the stuff that
you do online
uh you can find me on instagram louise
nicola or the diamondboss is my handle
or if you really want to get more
information on brain health upgrading
brain performance you can go to our sub
stack which is neuroathletics dot sub
stack dot com sweet we made it thank you
louisa
chris what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace